so what I want to talk about now our
shapes of distributions in different
words we might use to describe those
shapes so right over here let's see
we're talking about Matt's cafe and we
have different age buckets so this is a
histogram here and in each bucket it
tells us the number of guests that are
in that age bucket so a lot of we don't
have any guests that are under the age
of 20 we have a reasonable number
between 20 and 30 we have a lot of
guests at 30 in that bucket between 30
and 40 reasonable number between 40 and
50 and then as we get older we have
fewer and fewer guests so just when you
look at something like this a
distribution like this something might
pop out at you it kind of looks like if
you were to imagine this were an
armadillo this would be the body of the
armadillo and then what we see to the
right would kinda looks like the tail of
the armadillo and we actually use those
types of words to describe distributions
so this distribution right over here it
looks like it has a tail to the right it
doesn't have a tail to the left in fact
we have no one under the age of 20 but
here when we have a few people between
60 and 70 even fewer between 70 and 80
even fewer between 80 and 90 and you
know it kind of keeps going like this
this is a tail and it's on the right
side it's a right tailed distribution so
I'd call this distribution right tailed
and I'm using Khan Academy exercises
because it's a good way to see a lot of
examples and and frankly you should too
because it will help you test your
knowledge but it's not left tail left
tailed we would see a tail going like
that and it frankly if you're left
tailed and right tailed you're likely to
be approximately symmetrical remember
symmetry that you define a line of
symmetry and one type of symmetry is one
where if you were to wear both sides of
that line of symmetry or kind of mirror
images of each other you could fold over
the line of symmetry and they'll roughly
meet and this one does not meet that
because if you were to say maybe there's
a line of symmetry here you're trying to
fold this over it wouldn't match up the
two sides would not match up so I feel
good saying that it is right tailed so
let's see retirement of age of each
guest
well yeah these names aren't that great
but let's actually see what they're
saying they're saying by age they're
telling us the number of guests so this
is this is a number of guests at a Logan
assisted living so we have a lot of
guests that are between 60 and 70 years
old or reasonable that are between 50
and 60 or 70 or 80 and this distribution
actually looks pretty symmetrical if I
were to draw a line of symmetry right
down here right at around an age of you
know I guess the line would be the right
at an age of 65 I guess you could say
all this is a bucket for ages 60 to 70
then you could flip it over and it looks
pretty symmetrical not exactly this
bucket doesn't quite match up to this
one but it's pretty close these roughly
match each other these roughly match
each other so I feel good about saying
it is approximately symmetrical now just
to know what these other words mean
skewed to the left or skewed to the
right these actually have fairly
technical definitions when you get
further in statistics but I guess easier
to process version of them are when you
have a left tail you tend to be when you
attend it when you are left tailed you
also tend to be skewed to the left and
when you are right tailed you tend to be
skewed to the right another way to think
about skewed to the left is that your
mean is to the left of your median mode
that might not make any sense to you you
might just want to go after the tail if
your left tail you're probably left
skewed if your right tailed you're
probably right skewed so let's keep
going let's see if we can see let's se
see another example so this is
interesting this is not we were not
given a histogram here we're not given a
bar graph we're given a box and whisker
plot which is really just telling us the
different quartiles so just to remind
ourselves this tells us the minimum of
our data set the bottom of our range so
the minimum value in our data set we
have at least one 11 and then the
maximum value of our data set we have at
least 125 now this line right over here
is the median the middle number is 21
and then the box defines the middle 50%
of our numbers so it's kind of the meat
of our the meat of our distribution so
if we were try to visualize what this
would look like as maybe a histogram and
we don't know for sure because we might
have a whole bunch of 11s but not so
much that it skews this but we could
have more than one but a distribution
that this could match up with is
something that looks like having a tail
down here and then you kind of bump up
here this is the meat of the
distribution it kind of looks something
like that and I can't draw because I'm
doing this on the exercises right now
but for something like that well
something like that would have a tail to
the left would have a tail
to the left it has its its range goes
you know fairly low to the left but it
might not have a lot of values there if
it had more values on the left side this
box would have been shifted over because
a larger percentage would have fit would
have been on the left so to speak and so
this one I feel pretty good about saying
this is skewed to the left it's
definitely not symmetrical if it was
symmetrical the median would be would be
pretty close to the center the box would
be pretty centered and it's not skewed
to the right if it was q' to the right
you would have a tail to the right you
would have this whisker would likely be
much much much longer and we're done